monsieur naturel employé à la station de
la croisière sur la nationale 20 près de
Limoges se distingue depuis longtemps
par la gentillesse dont il fait preuve à
l'égard des automobilistes vous venez
d'être honoré d'un titre de quel titre
s'agit-il
premier prix de la mobilité des Français
quoi vous avez été reçu à Paris
chez vous de
tous les complices de quoi au bon
accueil que nous réservons notre
clientèle parfait je présume que vous
avez une récompense
pour deux personnes moi et ma femme je
vous félicite et je vais vous laisser
travailler j'espère que beaucoup de
complices pendant cet exemple sur vous
merci
monsieur
[Musique]